hey guys it's Friday October 27 all the
biggest games are outs I'm Callie I'm
chassis I don't know what to play first
but it's probably going to be Mario Jess
and Dan are at PAX but we're here with
your top five stories of the week first
up it seems Metal Gear survive will be
always online a page on the games
website contains the disclaimer that
quote an internet connection is required
to play the game and that's for all
three platforms ps4 Xbox one and PC a
separate note specifies that PS Plus or
xbox live goal will be required for
online multiplayer which is to be
expected but the distinction is what's
telling here Metal Gear survived is a
spin-off of mgs 5 the phantom pain with
a focus on survival action its main game
modes are single-player and co-op so I'm
not exactly sure what this internet
connection requirement is about metal
your survive is set to release February
20th in the US and 22nd in Europe but
unfortunately no Australia or New
Zealand release date has yet been
announced if you were hoping for GTA 5
story DLC you're out of luck Rockstar
Games never promised it would release
single-player expansions for GTA 5 but
some fans hoped they would and GTA 4 had
some great story add-ons like The Ballad
of Gay Tony and the lost and the damned
instead rockstar is focusing on updates
for GTA online which have been plentiful
which makes sense because it's a big
moneymaker for rockstar Rockstar said it
came down to a lack of resources and the
company's focus on Red Dead Redemption -
which we're still looking forward to
even though it's still in early access
smash hit pub G is getting a disc
release on Xbox one the Xbox release is
still slated for late 2017 which is
pretty much now Microsoft is reportedly
trying to keep it a console exclusive
for as long as possible
developer blue Hall has only said the
team is solely focused on bringing the
best game possible to Xbox one and PC
pub G recently surpassed two million
concurrent's on Steam so I'm very
interested to see how it performs on
Xbox finally original Xbox games are now
backwards compatible on Xbox one like
with Xbox 360 games only select ones are
available so far and in this slate there
are 13 included our ninja gaiden black
Psychonauts Prince of Persia sands of
time and my personal favorite Star Wars
Knights of the
if you still have the disk somewhere you
can put it in your xbox and start
playing or buy a digital version through
the store you won't be able to play
online multiplayer with any of these
because support for those games has been
shut down but you will of course be able
to play local multiplayer the next set
of original Xbox games coming to
backwards-compatibility is set for
spring 2018 which is a longer way than
we're used to for 360 games but that
gives you plenty of time to play through
kotor again the Xbox Kinect sensor is
officially dead rest in pieces Microsoft
revealed this week that they have
officially stopped manufacturing the
device meaning the ones in stores are
the last ones you can get however
support for the device will continue the
Xbox one s didn't even come with a port
for the Kinect and neither will the Xbox
one X good riddance we say the Kinect is
always listening it has recorded our
most embarrassing dance central moments
in fact we have a very special guest
here who is a personal victim of the
Kinect our very own Nicolas Margherita
Nick tell us your story Christmas
morning which is supposed to be a
morning of celebration and joyous
activity and all I wanted to do was play
Kinect Sports and little did I know it
was posting each and every one of my
highlight videos on my Facebook newsfeed
so Nick about how many videos were
posted by the Kinect before you were
aware of it well there were about 25
separate videos posted by the Kinect
sports app unbeknownst to me and against
my personal wealth so not really sure
how many people saw it but all I can say
it was quite embarrassing I'm so sorry
what a violation of your privacy and
thank you for sharing back to you
chastity well let us know what you think
of the Kinect and the rest of the
stories from this week and the comments
below and be sure to check out the
reviews of all the games that came out
today we've got Super Mario Odyssey
we've got Wolfenstein 2 from Kali and we
also have Assassin's Creed origins over
on GameSpot calm jess and Dan we'll be
back Monday thanks for joining us and
have a great weekend
[Music]